very competitive races for Clark County
Commission three seats are up for
re-election in this case of course tick
sarger Bloom who is one of the County
commissioners of Fort reelection sir
good to see you once again thank you
talking about your re-election campaign
uh before we get to some of the issues
that are happening in the in the
district one of the main issues that's
happening all across uh the city we've
been talking so much about the case of
Rob tell us the Clark County public
administrator now accused of murdering
the review journal investigative
reporter Jeff gearman
um there have been a lot of stories and
the RJ did a story just recently about
the County's response to the complaints
buy people in Mr telus's office about
his performance and why nothing was
really done can you explain from your
point of view as a commissioner what you
saw and what was done to try and address
some of the concerns
well first off you have to remember that
that his office he's elected so we don't
have the ability to get in there and
just take it over or kick him out or do
anything initially so I think there were
complaints they didn't actually surface
to my level
but you know those are normal I
shouldn't say the normal they appear to
be normal Personnel matters that's one
things I did in private practice as a
lawyer so I'm aware of how that all fits
together
but obviously we didn't take it
seriously enough we didn't act fast
enough
and and then this tragedy happened which
is just unbelievable frankly there have
been other issues that have been raised
there have been articles in the rjs they
mentioned this in the issues with the
former coroner John feudenberg
constables issues with money issues with
working on and off the clock
what
how can you guarantee for voters that
there is enough oversight whether these
people are elected or they're appointed
enough oversight from the County
Commissioners and from you of people who
are elected to run these important
offices well again the the length
historically the problem was they are
elected so we don't want to give the
micromanage something that the voters
have spoken for but obviously we need to
pay more attention going forward these
were once very small offices now they're
huge offices of tons of employees but
the other thing is truthfully there's no
reason to elect those positions they in
this day and age they should be
appointed by the County Commission and
then you can always directly responsible
there's no way fans or butts we pick the
person if there's a problem we fix it if
we don't fix it then come after us but
even in the case hypothetically of of Mr
Telus acknowledging he's an elected
official and you know you're an elected
official as well as a commissioner don't
you have the weight to at least do
something well again it
but truthfully I was not aware of those
issues so maybe we should have it more
we should be more directly involved in
our staff monitoring his staff
but that's one of their issues is how
How Deeply involved the County
Commissioners we have you know thousands
of thousands of employees we have 50
some agencies do we have do we
micromanage those as Commissioners
elected officials or do we have our
staff do that so again I would want to
justify it I think we screwed up big
time but hopefully you learned from the
past and and so we are all much more
Vigilant about what goes on those
especially those whether we call
Independent agencies would you consider
something if you're re-elected to maybe
make those kind of changes so it's not
sort of as you're describing you know
above my pay grade seems to be the
explanation from from you no absolutely
and one of the things we're going to do
is go the legislature and asked to have
those positions taken out of the
election cycle that there's no
we get good people in historically we've
had good people but there truly is no
reason to have them elected in a county
of two plus million people no one knows
who the public Guardian is no one who's
those positions are not something where
people can actually meet them
let's switch gears and talk about your
time as Clark County Commissioner you've
been in an office since 2019 you have a
long history of course in local politics
talk about some of the achievements that
you can point to during your time on the
Clark County Commission where obviously
that includes the pandemic a lot of
things have come up in these last almost
four years absolutely when I got elected
we were just coming out of a long period
of of slow growth things we're picking
up you know we the county was actually
going to have some money finally so we
were looking at forward to to
um you know really trying to do some
Innovative things and then literally one
year after I was there the pandemic hit
this trip shut down it's never happened
before in history we live on the Strip
where the the the Revenue tax revenue
from the strip pays our government so we
literally went into the panic mode we
didn't know what to do so we we our
Focus first off was how do we keep
everybody alive so we worked with them
as far as the the we didn't have
vaccines yet but we were the masking
trying to figure out how to get the
economy back up but we also had the
layoff we didn't want to lay off the
government employees so we put a freeze
in a lot of people retired early because
we offered a little incentive there and
then slowly things came back but it's
been one thing after another people
being evicted so we had to come up with
a program for that we had to have food
we had massive food banks I mean we this
we've never seen anything like the first
that two-year period so I just want to
brag about that that we did I think
overall we did a fantastic job for
something we were never prepared to do
what do you tell small business owners
that are still struggling to recover
whether it's lack of Revenue lack of
employees
that were affected by those pandemic
closures during the depths of
coronavirus well you know my door is
always my phone's always open if you
have a financial problem because of
those issues I can't obviously help with
with new employees because everybody
just stretched to the Bone I mean we
kind of we have a thousand positions we
can't fill and those are good jobs so
it's just it's it's the the economy has
changed but if you have a problem with
with taxation or government regulation
or or anything you know we will bend
over backwards to help you we do have
some grants available to help people so
we are totally sympathetic and we're
we're there to try to help on the front
lines as far as anything we can do to
help you because small business
obviously is very key to this and a lot
of them come back frankly so it's it's
amazing how resilient our economy has
been
an issue that certainly is uh close to
your heart is uh legal marijuana which
is uh an ongoing issue to try and get
those pot lounges in place it's been a
bit of a slow roll the Hope was to open
it have them open in Clark County in the
summer that hasn't happened yet uh where
do things stand right now and what are
you hoping to try and push through
moving forward well
you know I passed the first marijuana
law in 2013.
you know went as soon as we passed it
the only place you could legally smoke
it was in your house which of course you
know terrorists don't have a house so I
mean it's like Hello how are we trying
to sell marijuana to people who can't
use it and so obviously it's been out
there people using it wherever and and
illegally but we we I honestly can see
the end of the tunnel is the state has
finally finalized their regulations
they're going to ask for applications at
the end of October we're putting
together our regulations to match those
so when any dispensary gets a permit
they'll be able to come if they want to
be in the county they can come to the
county right away and we'll be ready to
take their application we have land use
our land use people are ready to
determine whether it's a good location
and we're going to be up and running but
it it's just amazing how long it's it's
literally been 20 23 10 years until
people could legally smoke something
which in my opinion never should have
been illegal another issue that kind of
from a state level coming down when it
comes to pot lounges is the issue of
short-term rentals that is another sort
of State Legislative
law that now Clark County is trying to
implement Clark County's implementation
it's some would suggest suggest it's
pretty strict is like at least with the
plans out right now why
well first off remember in Clark County
nothing is legal right now they say
there are 10 000 airbnbs but but none of
those are legal so everybody that has
one right now is breaking the law the
state gave us and this was where the
state worked out well I think because
they said you have to have an ordinance
by a certain date as opposed to well
we'll do ours and then you have to
follow it so they they said by the first
of July we had to have our ordinance
ready and then we had six months to
implement it but so we started out with
I think around a thousand airbnbs that
we're going to permit to see how it goes
but we have no idea you know the Airbnb
won't talk to us so we don't know how to
how their system works I mean they could
easily hook their computer up to our
computer and we could know every Airbnb
in the county we could go out and try to
violate them or bring in tax revenue the
other thing they don't pay room tax that
the hotels have to pay so there's a lot
of moving pieces to it but again that's
one where I think we're actually going
to do well I mean if it turns out the
Thousand is too little and and the
public likes it great but you know the
fact is HOAs aren't allowed to have them
so but you basically push them into my
older neighborhoods and a lot of older
neighborhoods didn't sell into this idea
that oh my neighbor can have a you know
an apartment complex that on a daily
basis I mean and then the parties I mean
it some of the things that go on are
pretty bad
um one of some of your opponents in the
upcoming election it's a crowded field
In fairness for your district has talked
about the neglect in their opinion of of
East County of the East part of Las
Vegas you just recently read an event to
sort of uh cutting the ribbon for the DI
bridge over on the east valley
how much have you focused on trying to
improve not only just Transportation but
parks and other resources to the eastern
part of the valley that some say has
been neglected well first off it's true
I mean I'm I'm kind of embarrassed for
our government the fact that East Las
Vegas has kind of been the stepchild I
mean if you drive the freeway drive 95
the Charleston exit on 95 is a disaster
there is no exit on Sahara why was that
ever done so I mean those people are
very landlocked one of the things I've
done is I've actually changed the
district borders for my district to
include more of East Las Vegas more make
it more Hispanic as a majority Hispanic
and because of that a lot of the
territories were talking about I didn't
have control over before but you know if
you look at Hollywood we redid Hollywood
we're redone doing the Hollywood
Recreation Center we're making a huge
um Sports Complex out there we just said
we did the DI Bridge we redoed all the
parks but there's much more that can be
done and and I I have to apologize for
for myself and for all of Clark County
government over the years that it's just
it's become this part where people
people work they go to Summerlin where
it has great facilities and then they go
home just to drive home is a nightmare
you drive out in Washington you drive
out of Bonanza you drive out Lake Mead
those streets are really slow so there's
a lot more we can do and that's one of
the things I want to do in the next four
years is is devote my attention to to
Bringing resources to East Las Vegas
like they have in Summerlin so let's
talk about moving forward if you're
elected for another four years whether
it's in the East part of the valley or
elsewhere in your District what do you
want to try and Achieve well first off I
said I want to bring the the
infrastructure to East Las Vegas that is
comparable or start at least the process
to build the interchanges to have the
freeways to have the roads so people can
get to work improve the park system I'm
actually going to create a thing with
with this try to Overlay of so the
schools in my district where we can try
to then devote County Detention to the
things that schools don't do but Focus
around the schools I've brought back the
Redevelopment agency so over here at
Maryland Parkway between Karen and
Sahara we're going to start to redevelop
that whole area which has been very
underserved so a lot of the my district
is poor a lot of it's been overlooked
for lack of reason because people want
to develop out in the southwest or the
Northwest but now because of the land
shortage actually developers are
starting to come back in and look at
some of these small pieces so there's
lots we can do
um you know it's it's it the focus is
now I think pushing things back into the
city which is East Las Vegas and and my
district so I'm very very excited and of
course I have part of this trip and the
strip you know we help Resort World get
open we're working on Fountain Blue
Sahara's back and revitalized so the
north part of this trip all night you
know they're working there right now so
I mean it's it's knock on wood but
there's never been a time like Las Vegas
right now and and I don't see we're
we're cyclical so every time we think
we're over it we always have a hump I
don't think we're going to have that
huge downfall I mean and once the
convention business is back in place
which again has been my district then I
think that the town will do well and
when the strip beds are full then East
Las Vegas does well right
commissioner Bloom running for
re-election sir thank you for coming in
once again good luck in the campaign
appreciate it so much